el número atómico se simboliza por z y
se refiere al número de protones en un
núcleo tu puedes encontrar el número
atómico en la tabla periódica entonces
en este vídeo hablaremos del hidrógeno y
para el hidrógeno su número atómico es
el 1 como está indicado aquí quiere
decir que hay un protón en el núcleo de
un átomo de hidrógeno ahora en un átomo
neutro el número de protones es igual al
número de electrones porque en un átomo
un neutrón o al carga total y las cargas
positivas de los protones están
completamente balanceadas con las cargas
negativas de los electrones entonces
dibujemos un átomo de hidrógeno
sabemos que el número atómico del
hidrógeno es el 1 entonces hay un protón
en el núcleo y como estamos hablando de
un átomo de hidrógeno neutro entonces
hay un electrón a este electrón lo
dibujo fuera del núcleo y utilizo el
modelo atómico de board ahora así no es
como se ve un átomo pero es una buena
manera para empezar a entender esto y
bueno esta es una versión del hidrógeno
es un isótopo del hidrógeno y es llamado
propio
entonces este isótopo de hidrógeno es
llamado propio y hablemos de isótopos
entonces bueno los isótopos son átomos
de un solo elemento aquí estamos
hablando del hidrógeno y que se
diferencian en el número de neutrones en
su núcleo entonces hablando del
siguiente isótopo de hidrógeno este es
llamado deuterio así que lo escribo
deuterio el deuterio es hidrógeno
entonces debe tener un protón en el
núcleo y debe tener un electrón fuera
del núcleo ahora si tú ves la definición
de isótopo son átomos de un solo
elemento que se diferencian en el número
de neutrones entonces se diferencian en
el número de neutrones mientras que el
deuterio tiene un neutrón en el núcleo
entonces al deuterio le voy a dibujar su
neutrón lo voy a bueno voy a dibujar a
los neutrones con color azul ahora el
deuterio como puedes ver tiene un
neutrón y los
eu throne es tienen masa entonces el
deuterio tiene más masa que el propio
los isótopos tienen diferentes masas
porque tienen diferentes números de
neutrones pero nota que tiene el mismo
número atómico tienen el mismo número de
protones en el núcleo tienen un protón
en el núcleo y eso es importante porque
si tú cambias el número de protones
estás cambiando el elemento ahora en
este vídeo estamos hablando de átomos de
un solo elemento el deuterio sigue
siendo hidrógeno es un isótopo del
hidrógeno y finalmente nuestro último
isótopo es el tritio el tritio tiene un
protón en el núcleo y un electrón fuera
del núcleo y se debe diferenciar de los
otros isótopos en el número de neutrones
entonces bueno el tritio tiene dos
neutrones los voy a dibujar estos son
los dos neutrones que tiene el tritio en
el núcleo y estos son los tres isótopos
del hidrógeno pero como distinguimos a
los diferentes isótopos lo que haremos
es escribir símbolos para representar
isótopos entonces bueno hagamos eso el
símbolo que usaremos para el propio
tendrá el símbolo del elemento del
hidrógeno aquí abajo escribimos el
número atómico que es 1 porque tiene un
protón en el núcleo entonces el 1 lo
ponemos en el subíndice en el súper
índice escribimos el número de masa aquí
abajo yo tengo la definición del número
de masa entonces bueno veamos la el
número de masa es el número combinado de
protones y neutrones en el núcleo
entonces protones y neutrones y al
número de masa se le simboliza por a a
es el número de masa que es igual al
número de protones que es el número
atómico lo simbolizamos por zeta
ajá entonces a es igual a z más el
número de neutrones así que a es igual a
z más n iv para el propio en el núcleo
sólo hay un protón y cero neutrones
entonces 10 eso nos da un número de masa
de 1 voy a utilizar el color rojo para
distinguir entre el número de masa y el
número atómico
entonces el número de masa estará en
color rojo tenemos uno y usar el color
rosa para representar al número atómico
entonces el subíndice representa el
número atómico que está representado por
z y el super índice es el número de masa
representado por a muy bien entonces
este símbolo representa al isótopo
propio así que escribamos el del
deuterio ese hidrógeno entonces pongo
una hache y sigue habiendo solo un
protón en el núcleo así que voy a poner
un número atómico de 1 y el número de
masa se pone en el súper índice y es el
número combinado de protones y neutrones
si observas el núcleo vemos que hay un
protón y un neutrón uno más uno eso es
igual a 2
entonces pongo un 2 en el súper índice y
finalmente para el tritio éste sigue
siendo hidrógeno entonces voy a poner
aquí el símbolo de hidrógeno y hay un
protón en el núcleo entonces tiene un
número atómico de uno y el número
combinado de protones y neutrones
sería en este caso de tres un protón dos
neutrones nos da tres y estos son los
isótopos del hidrógeno utilizar estos
símbolos nos ayuda a diferenciar los
ahora practiquemos con el carbono aquí
tenemos el símbolo del carbono con
subíndice 6 y super índice 12 muy bien
si quieres saber cuántos protones
electrones y neutrones tiene hagamos lo
siguiente primero pensemos en protones
sabemos que el subíndice es el número
atómico y el número atómico es el número
de protones entonces hay 6 protones en
este átomo de carbono y si es un átomo
neutro de carbono entonces el número de
electrones debe ser igual al número de
protones si hay 6 protones también debe
haber 6 electrones entonces también hay
6 electrones muy bien ahora finalmente
como averiguamos el número de neutrones
bueno pues para esto vamos a escribir la
fórmula tenemos que la fórmula es
el número de masa es igual al número
atómico más el número de neutrones así
que bueno el número de masa aquí está es
este 12 entonces ponemos aquí 12 el
número atómico es 6 aquí está este 6
entonces colocamos aquí en el número
atómico un 6 y sumamos los neutrones + n
por lo tanto el número de neutrones es
igual a 12 menos seis hacemos la resta
eso es igual a 6 así que tenemos 6
neutrones entonces solamente restamos el
número atómico del número de masa y así
es como obtuvimos el número de neutrones
en nuestro átomo muy bien hagamos otro
ejercicio aquí tenemos al carbono pero
esta vez con un súper índice de 13 ahora
el número atómico no cambia cuando
hablas de isótopos porque entonces
cambiarías el elemento entonces aquí
tenemos 6 protones en el núcleo de este
átomo
un átomo neutro debe ver el mismo número
de protones que de electrones entonces
tenemos 6 protones y 6 electrones y
finalmente cuántos neutrones tenemos
bueno pues justo como lo hicimos antes
restamos el número atómico del número de
masa entonces hacemos la resta 13 menos
6 13 menos 6 y así vamos a averiguar el
número de neutrones en este átomo 13
menos 6 eso es igual a 7 por lo tanto
hay 7 neutrones en este átomo ahora otra
manera de representar isótopos es
digamos que queremos representar este
isótopo de una manera distinta algunas
veces lo verás así el nombre del
elemento escrito en este caso tenemos
carbono luego pones un guión y el número
de masa entonces carbono 13 que se
refiere a este isótopo de carbono y a
esta anotación con el nombre del
elemento un guión y el número de masa
podríamos llamarle por llamarlo de
alguna forma notación de guión muy bien
hagamos
ejemplo más que se ve un poco más
difícil vamos a trabajar con el uranio
la uv es de uranio el número atómico del
uranio es el 92 y el número de masa para
este isótopo será del 235 veamos cuántos
protones neutrones y electrones hay en
este átomo de uranio así que una vez más
para protones observamos que el número
atómico es de 92 entonces debe haber 92
protones en un átomo neutro el número de
electrones es igual al número de
protones así que hay 92 electrones y
finalmente para averiguar el número de
neutrones restamos este número al número
de masa así que hacemos el cálculo 235
menos 92 eso es igual a 143 por lo tanto
hay 143 neutrones